en las cosas que creo que diferencia a
los seres humanos de otras especies es
nuestra capacidad de tener
simultáneamente ideas y pensamientos en
nuestra cabeza contradictorios
cuántos de nosotros aquí por ejemplo
amamos a alguien pero por momentos lo
odiamos
cuántos de nosotros sentimos miedo a
algo pero a la vez esperanza de poder
afrontar ese miedo
yo tengo miedo al cambio climático
pero a la vez esperanza que podremos
afrontarlo son muchos los motivos que
nos dejan innumerables imágenes de ríos
comunidades océanos inundadas por
residuos
y en la charla de hoy me gustaría hablar
de uno de los motivos
que nos dejan en semejante encrucijada
climática
el capitalismo
el capitalismo en busca de su máxima
rentabilidad es uno de los
factores más importantes por los que nos
encontramos como nos encontramos
plásticas subidas de temperatura
tormentas y tifones cada vez más
intensos y un mayor índice de
propagación de enfermedades son solo
algunas de las causas o consecuencias de
este cambio climático
pero y si os dijera que podemos la
increíble fuerza del capitalismo
y transformarla para que en vez de que
sea un problema sea un aliado por el
cambio climático
yo soy fondo luján y creo que el
capitalismo es decir mejor dicho la
basura canalizada a través del
capitalismo puede ser la solución a este
a este problema
en los últimos 100 años las economías
mundiales
capitalistas han crecido de manera
exponencial al igual que nuestras bolsas
de valor pero el problema es que este
crecimiento sin precedentes en la
historia de la humanidad se ha venido
alimentando por energías fósiles
abundantes y muy baratas que lo que han
conseguido ha sido cambiar nuestro clima
y nuestro entorno
[Música]
un poco por por explicar un poco por qué
estamos como estamos en el último siglo
definimos capitalismo como la búsqueda
de riqueza e ingresos en el mercado es
decir agentes y empresas crean productos
y servicios que venden en este mercado y
si lo que generan es mayor a su coste
obtienen un beneficio bien
las empresas pueden hacer este cálculo
porque todo lo que se necesita para
crear estos productos o servicios tienen
asociado asociados números que nosotros
denominamos precios
bien en cualquier libro de economía
sabemos que el precio de algo siempre va
a subir el coste de esto no tendría
ningún sentido vender algo por debajo de
lo que nos ha costado producirlo pero
por desgracia la vida muchas veces no es
como la pintan los libros y las
películas y hay casos que en el mercado
existen productos que se venden por
debajo de su coste si esto sucede la
tendencia natural del mercado es que el
producto se consuma en exceso y es lo
que los economistas llamamos fallo de
mercado
permitidme que os dé un ejemplo en los
últimos 100 años la energía fósil
producida por el carbón tiene un precio
muchísimo más bajo que el su coste
el coste de quemar esta energía nos ha
costado
el aire que respiramos
y nos ha costado también nuestra
atmósfera pero para los compradores de
esta energía
este precio este coste no estaba
asociado en el precio
el año pasado el fondo monetario
internacional asumió que los costes no
asociados a las energías fósiles como la
de carbón ha supuesto a nuestra economía
más de 7 mil millones de euros
se puede asumir así que el cambio
climático es el mayor fallo de mercado
de la historia del capitalismo
y no me malinterpretéis yo no seré el
que diga que el capitalismo no ha
conseguido cosas increíbles para nuestra
sociedad pero la preservación del cambio
climático no ha sido una de ellas
muy conscientes de este problema en la
solución de nuestros gobiernos o la
reacción natural de nuestros gobiernos
ha sido la creación de políticas
tasas incluso penas carcelarias para
intentar limitar
esta maximización del beneficio
lo que pasa es que este tipo de política
es muy común en el mundo en el mundo
occidental
es un tipo de política denominada
comando y control
para los que tendréis niños sabréis
mucho mejor que yo qué
gobernar bajo políticas de leyes y
castigos puede derivar en
cierta revolución en casa cuando los
niños sean adolescentes y eso es
precisamente lo que ha pasado nuestros
mercados empresas y grandes
corporaciones hecha la ley hecha la
trampa han buscado la manera y han
invertido cientos de millones de euros
en abogados lobbies grupos de presión
con el fin de limitar esta imposición a
reducir la maximización del beneficio
bien y esta dinámica de creación de
leyes por un lado y resistencia por
parte de las empresas por otro se ha
visto resuelto en innumerables juzgados
senados congresos en todo el mundo dando
a entender un mensaje muy erróneo que lo
que es bueno para la industria no lo es
para el planeta y lo que es y viceversa
pero esto no es así
hemos dedicado los últimos cinco años de
nuestra vida a demostrar que es posible
y canalizar el capitalismo para resolver
el problema climático trabajamos en
vertederos no controlados
que nos venden está la materia prima
antes de que la quemen la inundan sala
tienen al mar o la ola en tierra en
introduciendo nuestra cadena alimenticia
y creando productos que luego vendemos
el problema aquí
es que la raza humana a finales del 2019
generará 300 millones de toneladas de
plásticos de las cuales aproximadamente
80 millones acaban en el mar
de estas se juntarán con las 250
millones que se estima que hay ahí y
sabemos también que el 87 por ciento de
estos residuos proceden de los países
más pobres y tiene sentido porque cuando
vives en la más absoluta miseria sin una
casa donde dormir comida que llevarte la
boca o incluso preocupada por tu propia
seguridad
el reciclaje es en la última de tus
prioridades
como he dicho estos países cogen la
basura y la compran a países ricos y la
queman la entierran
o la abierta al mar mi trabajo consiste
en hablar con estos vertederos comparar
esa basura antes de que la que me
entierren o viertan al mar y
transformarlos en un producto que luego
posteriormente vendemos y financia becas
de educación para evitar así la
degradación del planeta la pobreza es
una de las causas más grandes que
tenemos por la degradación del planeta
como he dicho antes
lo que está claro y lo que ha aprendido
en estos cinco años es que la basura la
que nosotros como la que nosotros
recolectamos lavamos catalogamos y
transformamos no es material inservible
el resultado de la descomposición o
destrucción de una cosa la basura es
dinero
dinero real
transaccional
que enriquece la vida de las personas
que entran en contacto con ella ya sean
ricos o pobres enriquece por ejemplo la
vía de leo
uno de los 26 propietarios de vertederos
no controlados con los que trabajamos a
las afueras de shenzhen en china que ya
no quema en tierra abierta al mar la
basura nos la venden dándole acceso a un
ingreso estable y de calidad cada mes
no es sólo basura
no es basura reciclada es basura social
basura que consigue también cambiar la
vida de personas como martín
que tiene acceso gracias a esta basura a
la educación una educación estable y de
calidad
y lo que quiero decir con esto es que no
seré yo quien diga que no existirán
fallos de mercado de nuestras economías
que hagan necesario el pago de tasas
como por ejemplo la tasa del co2 ni
tampoco que no tiene que haber leyes
medioambientales que exijan a empresas o
requieran que estas empresas se cubran
de su mala praxis pero lo que tenemos
que conseguir es demostrar canalizar a
través del capitalismo
está esta basura para poder
venderla para un valor añadido en la
sociedad eso es lo que tenemos que
conseguir y está en nuestras manos en
manos de nuestros manos de empresas y
agentes y usuarios conseguir que la
basura no sea solo basura sino sea la
materia prima y cambie la manera en la
que vemos nosotros la sociedad pasar de
una sociedad del consumo donde importa
muy poco el material con lo que se hacen
las cosas a una verdadera sociedad de
consumo donde lo importante es el
material y el mundo del que depende si
somos capaces de hacer eso salvaremos el
planeta si no somos capaces de hacer eso
la madre naturaleza evolucionará como yo
lo he hecho durante más de 6 mil
millones de años y nosotros no estaremos
listos para evolucionar con ella
muchas gracias